my name is rich roll I'm 49 years old
I'm a husband I'm a father of four kids
people know that I am an ultra endurance
athlete who's done some crazy stuff but
I think most people know me from the
books that I've written and then two
podcasts the rich world podcast a liar's
the big thinkers across all categories
of health wellness fitness diet
nutrition when I discovered drugs and
alcohol it was almost like the solution
to every problem that I never knew that
I had and so I went to rehab where I
lived for a hundred days but that
experience really saved my life
and as a newly sober person I became
initially very intent upon getting back
into that grind of climbing the
corporate ladder and so by the time I
was 39 from an outside perspective
looking in on my life my life looked
really good but on the inside I felt
like I was stuck in somebody else's life
I was about 50 pounds overweight working
as a corporate lawyer it was late one
evening and was making my way up a
simple flight of stairs
to go to sleep when I had to pause
halfway I was winded out of breath
tightness in my chest and really fear in
my heart I thought I was on the
precipice of having a heart attack
this was another one of those moments
very similar to that day that I got
sober
the first thing that I did was a
seven-day vegetable juice cleanse which
was something you know I'd never gone 24
hours in my entire life about eating
solid food but ultimately I fell into
eating a plant-based diet no animal
products on my plate and that really
revitalized me I actually think that
eating a plant-based diet is not only a
fantastic way to achieve your athletic
potential it is also one dietary
protocol that's been shown to prevent
and even reverse a litany of chronic
lifestyle diseases that are
unnecessarily plaguing our society with
this resurgence of vitality I actually
had a desire to start working out again
and that's really what led me to this
quest of trying to test what I'm capable
of and ultimately that's what directed
me into the world of ultra endurance
sports and the Ultraman World
Championships which is a double Ironman
distance triathlon that circumnavigates
the Big Island of Hawaii and then in
2010 doing epic five ultra endurance
sports has done nothing but improved my
life remaining active pushing my body I
think these are very healthy pursuits
and I can tell you that I'm much
healthier now than I was at 39 at 35 at
even 30
you